it's been called the death of cambodia's
democracy a court in the capital phnom
penh has jailed dozens of opposition
figures they were convicted of
conspiring to commit treason rights
groups say the entire process was a sham
accusing long-time leader hun sen of
using the mass trial to crack down on
dissent and hold on to power
in a trial aimed at suppressing
dissenting voices terry sang one of the
accused made it clear she had come to
defend liberty
i am freedom
i am your breath
you cannot live well without me
across the road in a courtroom seng and
60 other dissidents many of them already
in exile were being tried for treason
the court alleges they helped plot the
return of the leader of the banned
cambodia national rescue party
once the ruling party's main rival
i am ready
for the sham verdict that will be
announced this morning which will be a
guilty verdict i am ready and prepared
to go to the notorious cambodian prisons
for my political opinions for my beliefs
i for my belief in democracy
as the verdict was announced seng's
prediction was borne out
she was found guilty and sentenced to
six years in prison
others received sentences of five to
eight years
shortly afterwards she was arrested and
bundled into a police car
scuffles then erupted between her
supporters and police
cambodian courts are widely believed to
be under the influence of prime minister
hun sen
seen here at local elections just over a
week ago
he has been leading cambodia for 37
years human rights groups say with
increasingly repressive methods
sen has effectively turned cambodia into
a one-party state by arresting and
prosecuting his critics
this trial appears to be his latest
attempt to stamp out any remaining
opposition
we can go now to bangkok and speak to
phil robertson the deputy director of
the asia division of human rights watch
phil welcome to dw news asia
you've spoken out very forcefully on the
conviction of these opposition party
members in cambodia on twitter today you
called it an outrageous violation of
rights could you run through exactly
what you mean
well these people have been hit with
trumped-up charges uh and basically
dragged in front of a court that is not
independent it is a kangaroo court that
does the bidding of uh the ruling party
and the prime minister of cambodia and
what we're seeing is um no real evidence
produced at these trials to prove the
cases of incitement uh or conspiracy
that these people are being accused of
uh and have now been convicted of
again it is just more of the same from
cambodia it's a single party state
that is using uh
unfair laws and and unjust courts to uh
go after the opposition and put them
away for long prison terms it is
again an action by the cambodian
government to try to wipe out what
remains of the political opposition and
further narrow uh political space in the
country
now the u.s cambodian lawyer and
campaigner terry singh who was one of
those convicted and we just saw her in
that piece she says people in cambodia
are living in a dictatorship now is she
right
oh she's absolutely right i mean it's
quite clear that the cambodian
government is becoming more dictatorial
by the day
rights abuses are expanding across the
country uh there is no political
opposition uh elected political
opposition really to speak of
uh you know hun sen and uh his his party
and his government uh basically control
all the levers of power and they're not
afraid to go after anyone that makes a
criticism on facebook or otherwise says
something negative about the government
now you just mentioned prime minister
hun sen what means do the international
community have to pressure him over this
and how likely are they to use them
well i think we need to see more
pressure on trade uh with cambodia uh
the european union has an existing uh
uh
everything but arms agreement with
cambodia and 20 of that was suspended
before the pandemic hit because of uh
labor rights violations i think that the
european union should go back to that
again and look at taking more uh frankly
uh cambodia is in clear violation of the
terms of the uh the eba agreement that
requires cambodia to uh follow existing
international human rights treaties and
labor rights conventions and and
cambodia is doing none of it
now critics of hong sen say that over
many years he has eliminated his critics
but specifically uh used the pandemic to
do this too
to what extent did he use covert 19 to
expand his authoritarian control
well he passed a an emergency law that
is breathtaking its scope it has not
been invoked but it
essentially allows him to do anything he
wants if he invokes that law
and he has used uh various different
provisions uh of law
against people who are criticizing him
on facebook saying that the covent
pandemic response in cambodia was not up
to snuff that for instance uh some of
the vaccines that they had received from
certain countries were not good
uh you know all the criticism that was
made online you know if you said
something on facebook about what the
prime minister is doing on covid you
could expect the next day or two that
the police wouldn't be knocking on your
door and that is the new reality in
cambodia that online surveillance
is now matched with real repression on
the ground with by the police and the
military who are completely in hoonsen's
camp
a pretty dim picture of this new reality
as you so describe it phil
more generally what's the state of play
when it comes to human rights in
cambodia
well we are seeing uh civil and
political rights being violated on a
regular basis this is freedom of
expression freedom of association it's
basically impossible to hold a uh
political protest in cambodia in the
capital city of ponom pen
uh people who are campaigning against uh
dams against land seizures against other
environmental issues that you know
affect people's basic lives are are
facing arrests
uh you know it's across the board uh
that we've seen a real tightening of
repression against anybody who uh raises
criticism against the government in
cambodia
that was phil robertson the deputy
director of the asia division of human
rights watch phil thank you very much